[Musique]
je m'appelle Franck Colin je suis
l'organisateur de l'affaire R cocaïne
et je vais vous raconter comment ça
s'est passé
[Musique]
l'appareil saisi s'apprêtait à décoller
de Punta Cana et de prendre la direction
et bien la région parisienne la cocaïne
circulait par centaines de kilos à bord
d'un avion privé dissimulé dans ses
valises prête à être livré en France et
par avion
aussitôt vous n'avez pas seulement
transporté 10 ou 20 kg dans l'avion vous
avez mis 700 kg à l'intérieur
[Musique]
l'affaire cocaïne c'est une affaire hors
norme c'est mieux que le film
quand on dit hier cocaïne évidemment il
y a herbe il y a surtout cocaïne
[Musique]
on les a piégés en fait
je vais crever dans ce pays
je sais que ça va être pire et ce fut
pire
[Musique]
en réalité ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que cette affaire ne commence pas par la
découverte et la saisie de 700 kg de
cocaïne dans 27 valises qu'on a embarqué
dans un Falcon 50 et qui s'apprête à
prendre les airs à l'aéroport donc de
Punta Cana c'est pas ça le début de la
faire cette histoire est née selon moi
avec Franck Colas
[Musique]
Julien Toulon et j'ai grandi à la
ceinture j'ai grandi dans un quartier
qui s'appelle la Cité Verte quartier
très populaire
j'ai commencé à travailler à l'âge de 13
ans 14 ans j'ai fait des petits boulots
par-ci par là et puis par hasard
je suis rentré dans la sécurité
et puis je gagnais 500 francs par soir
tu vois 500 francs par soir c'est pas
mal d'argent quand même pour une gamin
il s'est construit tout seul en fait en
gravissant les marches de l'échelle
sociale
[Musique]
il est pétri de qualité ce garçon il est
aussi pétri de défaut il a été agent de
sécurité
et puis c'est un peu spécialisé
finalement dans dans l'activité de
physionomiste dans les boîtes de nuit de
la région il est originaire donc du Var
un gros bosseur il était tous les jours
à la salle il s'entretenait il faisait
attention à ce qu'il mange à ce qui ne
buvait pas
il était vraiment focus sur son objectif
qui était de prouver à tout le monde qui
pouvait être le garde du corps de toutes
les stars le garde du corps de tous les
gros clients j'adorais ça en fait la
sécurité c'était mon truc le fait
d'avoir manqué de sécurité plus jeune
m'a poussé là-dedans
et c'est comme ça que je suis venu à la
protection rapprochée en le faisant un
petit un petit CV avec quelques
célébrités du show business connu
[Musique]
qui en plus se faisait sa renommée dans
dans notre milieu de la sécurité c'est
que il était constamment au contact de
de très bons clients et de grosses stars
et j'ai pu accompagner Mania Mariah
Carey tu vois j'ai monté les marches du
Festival à Cannes avec Naomi Campbell à
l'époque où elle était encore tu vois
bien connue de toutes les tabloïdes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lors d'une altercation je rencontre
un client du VIP qui me voit
intervenir dans une histoire et puis
maîtriser un conflit il me dit tiens je
pars en Roumanie est-ce que tu veux
venir avec moi
mon père ne veut pas me laisser aller
tout seul donc j'ai besoin de quelqu'un
et je lui dis OK et je pars avec lui et
j'ai passé 6 ans le protéger c'est
quelqu'un que très riche il est très
généreux et finalement le la fortune que
francolin a fait provient de cette
générosité c'était les vacances tout le
temps deux fois en hiver deux mois à
Saint-Tropez l'été
[Musique]
j'ai invité tous ses amis quand il
venait à Saint-Tropez tout le monde
profitait de la maison de location il
venait en jet
je fais un mariage magnifique c'est
vraiment le compte de fait parfait quoi
c'est-à-dire le beau château
la belle robe de mariée la belle mariée
et tout et donc mon fils né
il se couche je dors avec lui je suis
par terre sur la moquette il tient mon
doigt
il se lève je suis là je débauche de
nounou infirmières dans un hôpital
d'enfant h 24 pas une deux c'est même
pas mon enfant c'est mon Dieu et c'est
mon Dieu à moi c'est ma chère c'est mon
sang
[Musique]
problème ce qu'il avait un gros train de
vie
Franklin voilà c'est quelqu'un qui aime
l'argent qui le dépense ouvertement et
donc il faut des ressources toujours
nouvelles pour pour assurer assumer
cette ce train de vie alors c'est
peut-être ça qu'il a poussé sur des
chemins un petit peu en dehors des clous
[Musique]
ce qui déclenche l'affaire c'est le fait
que les finances descendent et donc là à
un moment donné je me suis dit ça ça
colle plus
[Musique]
nous sommes pendant l'été peut-être au
mois de juillet 2012 Saint-Tropez l'été
c'est un petit peu the place to be pour
les gens qui aiment les paillettes
[Musique]
de dire que c'est dans la nuit que ce
gère toutes les affaires du jour donc
dans les carrés VIP c'est vrai que il y
a des superstars il y a des acteurs il y
a des chanteurs il y a des hommes
politiques et voilà notre Franck Colin
qui retourne au VIP Room
et dans cette boîte de nuit le VIP Room
il va rencontrer au carré VIP il va
rencontrer donc un personnage
le Ryan c'est carrément le personnage
clé de l'affaire puisqu'il est présenté
comme le commanditaire donc comme celui
qui est en lien avec les fournisseurs de
cocaïne de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
tu as des gens que tu connais qui font
partie d'une certaine
élite à Paris et vu que les trois quarts
des mecs ils prennent de la coque
à ce à ce stade là donc forcément ils
sont en relation avec des gens qui en
vendent et qui en vendent beaucoup
[Musique]
le carré VIP du VIP Room c'est là que on
compare virilement son ego à celui de
l'autre sa fortune sa belle montre sa
belle voiture par rapport à ceux de
l'autre on sait de là ils se sont
trouvés ils parlent belmontent ils
parlent belle voiture son attention à
peut-être été attiré par le côté bling
de Ryan on lui prête des montres de luxe
des belles voitures c'est quelqu'un qui
peut-être avait tendance à flamber à
aller dans le paraître et c'est quelque
chose qui a pu attirer
Franck Colin qui était aussi friand de
ce genre de soirée de milieux on
s'entend et Franck Colin se présente
leur dit voilà si un jour vous avez
besoin
de transiter d'un point à un point B je
sais faire
mais sans penser à de la drogue ça peut
être n'importe quoi parce que j'ai vu du
n'importe quoi j'ai vu des transports de
personnes sans papiers j'ai vu des
transports de lingots d'or pour des gens
très riches j'ai vu ça donc je me suis
dit s'il y a je connais
[Musique]
mais avec des ailes
aurait été conclu à ce moment-là
[Musique]
les narcos ils viennent me voir nous ça
nous intéresse mais comment ça
fonctionne moi je vous pose des
questions je leur dis voilà ça pardon tu
aurais pu lui dominicaine ok donc est-ce
que ça peut aller jusqu'à Saint Tropez
ouais pour nous ça nous pose pas de
problème donc ça sera Saint Tropez
[Musique]
sachant qu'à l'époque Frank Colin et sa
petite famille vivent en Roumanie ils
viennent à Saint-Tropez en jet privé et
leur pilote n'est autre que Alain
castani qui va se retrouver à une
position centrale de la faire
[Musique]
donc à la Castany pilote la viande le
jet privé
et là donc il se lit d'amitié sur un vol
aller-retour
sont des personnages qui est mort là qui
sont qui sont assez similaires avec
beaucoup d'entrains beaucoup de Babou
lui il me raconte un peu ces péripéties
tout ce qu'il a pu faire un peu dans sa
vie
des pilotes et les gens qui connaît et
voilà comment notre relation commence à
se concrétiser un petit peu c'est un
personnage assez charismatique très
sympathique voilà un peu un peu grande
gueule côté que j'aime bien sympa et
c'est comme ça qu'on qu'on nous pas
d'amitié du tout mais de relation
copains un peu plus que business
c'est quelqu'un qui est devenu ce qu'on
appelle un broker dans le monde
fermé de l'aviation d'affaires
c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui met en
relation
des clients qui ont besoin d'un avion
privé et des compagnies qui louent ces
avions privés avec son affaire c'est un
petit monde c'est une niche de par le
mode de déplacement par les le prix que
ça coûte c'est pas accessible à monsieur
tout le monde donc il y a des gens qui
sont connus comme utilisateurs et qui
passe par des brokers un peu la jambe de
voyage pour les personnes Lamb fin 2012
il contacte à la castani
je lui dis voilà ça se passe en Amérique
du Sud donc en République Dominicaine
c'est pour telle période est-ce qu'on
fait où on fait pas mais on fait ok pas
trop Stanic c'est bon je gère tout il
faut en parler avec personne tout se
passe à travers moi que ça soit les
montants que ça soit les les trajets
tout passe à travers moi et puis de là
il me dit ben je vais te présenter les
gens qui vont y aller l'avion qu'ils ont
c'est l'avion parfait pour le faire
[Musique]
donc c'est un Falcon de 50 à une société
qui s'appelle sfhs
Tani il est en lien d'amitié avec
Fabrice Alco actionnaire de la société
snths avec son autre associée et qui le
gérant qui s'appelle Pierre Marc Dreyfus
notre idée c'était vraiment
de faire une compagnie qui nous
correspondait une compagnie qui était
qui aurait été sérieuse qui aurait été
vrai c'était bien
c'était ce qu'on voulait c'est
essentiellement une société qui est le
fait de passionné d'aviation et étant le
fait de passionner l'aviation ce qui les
intéresse c'est surtout de pouvoir voler
de continuer dans le milieu de
l'aviation
[Musique]
j'ai été pilote pendant des années
j'adorais ça c'est un très beau métier
c'est un métier de passionné qui permet
de rencontrer des personnages
extraordinaires chaque vol est une
aventure entre guillemets la boîte
tournait bien on avait des Falcon 10
donc vous aviez un peu plus petit qui
tournait beaucoup qui tournait avec les
propriétaires et les propriétaires
l'utilisaient donc on avait une activité
tout à fait correcte on avait des
clients on avait récupéré nos avions on
avait récupéré de nouveau marché j'avais
obtenu
une promesse de près d'une banque qui va
permettre de changer de locaux on avait
un très bel avenir devant nous
Alain castani je le connaissais depuis
une quinzaine d'années c'est pas un ami
mais c'est une relation d'affaires tout
à fait tout à fait normale il m'a amené
des clients pour qui nous avons fait des
vols pendant des années et des années où
ça s'est toujours tout à fait bien passé
je crois pas qui est grand monde au
Bourget qui puisse vanter d'être aller
au Bourget sans avoir connu un castagnie
et une quinzaine d'années
Monsieur Alain castani du fait de
l'ancienneté de ses relations avec
Monsieur Elko de la notoriété qu'il a au
Bourget
est un en fait une caution morale
c'est-à-dire que on a par définition
confiance en monsieur Castanet ça fait
plusieurs fois que des contrats sont
signés il a apporté de nombreux clients
dont certains qui sont très connus soit
des politiques soit des stars soit des
humoristes donc on n'a pas de crainte on
n'a pas de défiance à l'égard de
Monsieur castani je le voyais à son
bureau pourront préparer d'autres
d'autres projets pour d'autres clients
donc je le voyais assez régulièrement il
m'a dit bah tiens j'ai rencontré des
gens cet été ils veulent avec telle
compagnie ils sont utilisateurs quand
ils viennent à Paris voici tu peux s'il
serait intéressant de travailler avec
eux
[Musique]
Franck Colin se présente aussi comme
quelqu'un qui a dans son relationnel un
douanier le douanier et Xavier manchot
[Musique]
François-Xavier manche un douanier qui
est un peu à sa dévotion qui en réalité
est en admiration devant lui se sont
connus il y a bien des années puis
retrouver bien plus tard c'est un ami de
longue date c'est un ami de presque de
30 ans
enfin c'était du moins
parce que ça l'est plus forcément les
erreurs de la vie mais ça ça coûte aussi
de l'amitié
[Musique]
sont donc revus à l'occasion d'une venue
de Colin sur le port de Toulon où
travaille manger
je pense que il vivait une espèce de vie
en décalé par procuration à travers
Franck Colin qui avait effectivement
fait fortune il est parti d'en bas et
puis en Roumanie il a eu des affaires il
a brassé beaucoup d'argent il a eu de la
chance Franck Colin jusqu'à une certaine
époque c'est le choc des cultures c'est
voiture de sport d'un côté et
l'austérité du douanier de l'autre mais
l'amitié ancienne fait que pour autant
s'apprécie et manger n'a pas de problème
avec l'argent il a réussi et une forme
d'admiration même pour ceux qui
réussissent par leur travail
François-Xavier ce qui brille les belles
voitures les soirées et il a pas hésité
à lui rendre plusieurs services
donc
l'affaire se concrétise même voire même
avant parce que elle ne peut pas se
concrétiser s'il n'est pas là c'est pas
possible
parce que il faut une sécurité à
l'arrivée
et la sécurité il y a pas mieux que le
capitaine de donne
donc avant quoi que ce soit il faut
parler avec le grenier c'est voilà mon
pote écoute il y a une affaire à faire
c'est des clients il y a un transporteur
moi je fais le lien et si tu es là c'est
mieux il y a pas de risque donc ça te
dit ou pas l'un des traits de
personnalité de manchers aussi c'est
sa simplicité l'argent de l'intéresse
pas
tout ce que peut procurer l'argent
lui étranger et lui pense comme moi je
m'en fous c'est pas moi qui achète c'est
pas moi qui vend c'est pas moi qui
transporte ouais t'inquiète je suis là
et si il y a un imprévu je l'écarte
[Musique]
on a aussi là encore à son service un
personnage qui s'appelle Nicolas Pisapia
[Musique]
je suis né à Marseille je suis
marseillais j'ai travaillé dans
l'immobilier ça m'a permis de rencontrer
beaucoup de personnalités d'hommes
d'affaires
de promoteurs ou d'investisseurs avec
qui je me suis lié d'amitié très vite et
j'ai pu les accompagner donc dans leur
déplacement en France puis à l'étranger
en Amérique latine en Afrique et en
Europe et en Europe de l'Est et en
Roumanie qui est mon pays de cœur
puisque je m'y étais établi
c'est un quelqu'un d'origine modeste qui
était pompier Marseille de la France qui
a rencontré
Franck Colin
et qui par l'intermédiaire de Franck
Colin
a connu une vie beaucoup plus facile
d'argent Roumanie
il va être notamment embauché par une
société qui travaille dans l'immobilier
mais une échelle très conséquente on le
présente comme un homme d'affaires il
n'a aucune affaire à cet homme là il a
essayé dans l'immobilier et dans le
sillage de francolin en Roumanie où
s'est installé de faire quelques
affaires tout tout a raté à moi il y a
en Roumanie depuis plusieurs années et
c'est une grandeur il a pris il a rien
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas d'argent qui
qui est nécessite qui vit en quelque
sorte parce que franconin le défoche il
lui donne de temps en temps quelques
activités subalterne pour essayer de
l'aider
il aime bien faire la fin comme tout le
monde c'est un jeune puis il se trouve
une nana
il reste avec
mais il galère elle allait stripteuse
dans un bar elle essaie de gagner sa vie
tant bien que mal lui il travaille sur
des plateformes téléphoniques où il
gagne 400 ou 500 balles à l'époque par
mois
et ils ont un petit garçon et moi les
enfants
[Musique]
mais donc je lui donne un peu d'argent
tu vois je lui dis voilà il y a un
projet qui va se qui va se faire
normalement et ce projet c'est d'aller
en République Dominicaine prendre du
stup et le déposer à Saint-Tropez
je me dis c'est quand même
costaud c'est dangereux je dis oui c'est
oui c'est dangereux il y a cet argent à
gagner et il y a ce risque à prendre
[Musique]
tu peux gagner beaucoup mais tu peux
tout perdre tu fais ou tu fais pas
[Musique]
il a une femme il a un enfant et il tire
le diable par la peur il y a une idée il
est donc prêt à tout et il va devenir
évidemment le passager entre guillemets
déguisé en homme d'affaires
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour Est-ce que vous
donc première réunion c'est même pas une
réunion préparatoire mais c'est une
réunion où tout le monde se présente un
petit peu enfin quand j'ai tout le monde
c'est moi moi Nicolas PISA Piat et
Castaldi qui est là il y a une réunion
qui est importante réunion à Paris et à
cette réunion sont présents évidemment
en Colin à l'un Castagnier
Fabrice ALKO et puis il y a également
Nicolas puisapiat dans le sillage de
Frank Colin
faut pas appeler ça à la Réunion c'était
un déjeuner prise de contact on essaie
de nous faire croire qu'il y a une
réunion avec des conditions
opérationnelles sur un quelconque trafic
ou quoi que ce soit il y a jamais ça
c'est tout à fait bien passé c'est
l'occasion pour aller à un castani pour
apporter l'adhésion de francolin de
faire l'article sur la compagnie capable
de transporter tout ce que l'on désire
il va également présenter les pilotes de
l'un est présent en disant ce sont des
ce sont des As ce sont des anciens
pilote de chasse ils sont capables de
poser un avion dans un champ de patates
[Musique]
les deux pilotes en fait c'est des
anciens pilotes de chasse dans les
années 90 ou même à la fin des années 80
ils étaient en poste
sur la base aéronavale de Hyères
ils ont participé à des opérations
militaires extérieure notamment dans le
cadre du conflit en exclusion de la vie
les deux pilotes ont été décorés pour ça
j'ai commencé en 80 dans la Marine
nationale pour être comme élève pilote
dans le but de venir pilote de
l'aéronavale j'étais en flotté une
chasse embarquée et comme j'arrive à la
au terme de mon contrat marine j'ai
re-signé dans l'armée de verre pour une
durée de 8 ans et je suis resté jusqu'en
99 dans l'armée de l'air dans un
escadron de combat aussi sur Mirage de
1000 à Luxeuil-les-Bains je fais 19 ans
de
dans les armées d'abord ces deux
militaires qui comme beaucoup de
militaires une fois leur carrière
militaire passées décident de prendre un
travail dans le privé et quand vous êtes
un pilote de ce niveau là en fait vous
avez deux solutions soit vous rentrez
dans une compagnie de ligne type Air
France soit vous rentrez dans une
société d'aviation d'affaires et je me
suis formé au métier de pilote
l'aviation civile j'ai trouvé une place
chez SNCF à Lyon c'était parfait pour
moi j'ai fait des tas de vols avec Bruno
dos on a vraiment sillonné
une bonne partie de la planète et le
soir souvent on disait si on pouvait se
construire notre compagnie etc on
demande notamment à Bruno Odos qui est
un très bon pilote et quelqu'un de très
structuré et quelqu'un de très
travailleur d'aider à développer la
société en permettant à cette société
d'opérer des vols transatlantiques
notamment et sur ces entrefêtes est
arrivé Pascal alors Pascal forêt je
dirais il a la tête de l'emploi il y a
un côté baroudeur grande gueule fumeurs
invétéré on imagine dans des histoires
pas possible de pilote il a de l'humour
voilà il est assez
[Musique]
on se connaissait de la marine on avait
fait une petite période dans la même
flottille trois quatre ans donc on se
connaissais d'avance qui est perdu de
vue puis on s'était retrouvé un petit
peu par hasard sur l'aviation d'affaires
c'est un petit monde très tôt il avait
quand même quelque chose qui était pas
ordinaire pour un enfant de son âge
c'est-à-dire qu'avant ses 5 ans il a dit
je veux être pilote un jour en entendant
un avion passé dans le ciel il était
chef d'escadrille spécialisé à pontage
de nuit sur le porte-avion puisque
c'était l'aéronavale donc plutôt
quelqu'un je dirais excellent dans son
domaine et qui faisait ça parce que
c'était sa passion et qui en a accepté
toutes les règles parce que c'était son
but depuis le début d'être pilote quoi
c'est des gens qui ont dédié leur vie à
la lutte contre le trafic à la lutte
enfin c'est des militaires en fait et
c'est des militaires qui sont très
engagés pour les valeurs de la France
pour le rayonnement de la France et donc
c'était déjà une énigme de voir ces deux
personnalités qui sont extrêmement
attachantes extrêmement intègres se
retrouver dans dans le cercle d'une
affaire criminelle
pourquoi Pascal foret est-il là il est
là parce qu'on lui a demandé de venir
son collègue
Bruno dos n'a pas pu se libérer on a
tous des emplois du temps assez chargés
et la Réunion est à Paris donc pour pas
faire des allers-retours en TGV assez
sang
et j'ai regardé sur le planning quel
était le
victime la plus proche
de Paris et c'est tombé sur Pascal il
est là en réalité pour faire ce que font
parfois les pilotes c'est-à-dire se
montrer pour assurer c'est moi qui vais
prendre des commandes de l'avion ben
voilà je me présente à vous pour vous
montrer que je suis quelqu'un de normal
très calme je vais vous rassurer vous
vous mettrez un visage sur celui qui
tient le manche à balai si jamais vous
aviez des inquiétudes à monter dans un
avion ça va vous rassurer on a déjà vu
ce cas de figure c'est à dire qu'on
avait déjà eu des clients qui voulaient
voir l'avion parce que
comme vous savez
beaucoup de gens ont peur en avion donc
ils veulent voir un peu le format
comment ils vont être dedans et puis
voir la tête des pilotes c'est vrai ça
nous on le perçoit pas mais en général
c'est ce qui regarde aussi donc c'est
comme ça qu'on l'a pris ce moi c'est
comme ça que je le prenais c'est à dire
qu'il fallait que il y a un premier
contact l'avion il le voyait pas mais il
avait peut-être déjà vu quelque part et
qui voit le pilote qui allait les
emmener alors destination ça paraissait
logique il y avait rien de préparatoire
au lieu de rassurer ceux qui sont
présents les les clients potentiels ces
forêts qui va être inquiété par
l'apparence de ses clients potentiels il
va les qualifier de barbouzes on a déjà
un premier signal d'alerte si je puis de
dire ainsi qui a dû s'allumer dans
l'esprit de de Pascal foret de voir à
qui il avait affaire ce qui a été très
difficile je crois pour Pascal foret
c'est d'expliquer cette espèce de
sentiment où vous trouvez que c'est
bizarre mais où vous trouvez pas que
c'est suffisamment bizarre pour sonner
la sonnette d'alarme quand on
reconstruit l'histoire c'est toujours
pareil c'est à dire qu'on se retrouve à
la fin d'une histoire avec des éléments
qui ont servi à nourrir le trouble
mais quand on y est il y a pas de
trouble voilà et donc en fait monsieur
foret il a le caractère d'un militaire
comme Monsieur audos c'est pas qu'il
pose pas de question ils sont pas
stupides mais ils sont pas là pour
lancer des alertes quand en gros
quelqu'un leur paraît pas conforme à
l'idée qu'on pourrait se faire de une
chose donc ils sont rentrés là dedans
avec cette mission
réalisée un vol transatlantique en toute
sécurité le premier vol il organisé il
est scellé il est organisé pour partir
en République Dominicaine partout Plata
répondu
la République Dominicaine est une plaque
tournante pour le trafic de drogue et
surtout pour la cocaïne provenant
d'Amérique du Sud
une grande quantité de drogues va d'une
part aux États-Unis et d'autre part
surtout pour la cocaïne en Europe
[Musique]
pour la drogue qui vient majoritairement
de Colombie tu Venezuela et dans une
moindre mesure du Pérou et de la Bolivie
il s'agit principalement de cocaïne et
d'héroïne
le prix d'un kilo de cocaïne augmente à
mesure que l'on s'éloigne de la Colombie
dans la jungle colombienne un kilo de
cocaïne d'après ce que l'on sait du
trafic de drogue d'après les données
avec lesquelles nous avons travaillé
cela coûte environ 300 400 ou 500
dollars selon la quantité achetée
mais lorsqu'elle quitte la Colombie il
se retrouve dans les Caraïbes le prix
augmente car ils doivent payer le
transport corrompre différentes
personnes et payer des gens pour
protéger la cargaison
des 300 dollars initiaux soit le prix
dans la jungle colombienne on peut
passer à 8000 dollars une fois la drogue
arrivée en République Dominicaine
en français cela peut très vite
atteindre une valeur comprise entre
35000 et 60000 dollars le kilo
le trafic de drogue est un crime
organisé qui dure depuis plus de 4
décennies depuis les années 80
si ce n'est avant
et des pays comme la République
Dominicaine alors même que nous ne
sommes ni producteurs ni consommateurs
subissent néanmoins les conséquences
tragiques de ce crime regrettable
[Musique]
je m'appelle Martha loussiafara
de colombienne et l'une de mes
spécialités en tant qu'avocat c'est de
m'occuper des personnes qui font l'objet
d'une demande d'extradition dans
différents pays notamment pour des
délits de blanchiment d'argent et de
trafic de drogue
donc quand on me dit eh tu as vu la
série sur telle ou telle chose je
réponds et bien c'est ce que je vis tous
les jours
d'après mon expérience avec les clients
que j'ai eu qui sont plutôt des
Colombiens l'Amérique centrale et
surtout la République Dominicaine sont
des étapes obligatoires pour le trafic
de drogue
je m'appelle Carlos
j'ai été impliqué dans le trafic de
drogue pendant environ 6 ou 7 ans
j'étais comme un commerçant je faisais
l'intermédiaire entre des clients et je
touchais une commission à la fois pour
le transport et la vente de marchandise
la République Dominicaine est un pays
important
pourquoi comme il s'agit d'un pays où il
y a beaucoup de corruption il existe des
moyens d'entrée dans chacun des ports
que ce soit par voie aérienne ou
maritime
grâce à ça ces marchandises peuvent être
envoyées vers toutes les destinations et
ici on est proche des codes de
l'Amérique du Sud
et le coup du matériel est bas
quand on fait des envois vers les pays
européens
la chaîne de production du trafic de
drogue ce n'est pas seulement qu'il a
produit mais aussi qui la transporte
qu'il la commande qu'il achète qui la
distribue et qui touche des commissions
c'est une chaîne
le premier voyage va donc être organisé
ce vol a décoller du Bourget il y a un
seul passager ce qui n'est pas normal
puisque en réalité il lui réduire en
avoir au moins 2 francolin et Nicolas
PISA Pia
et puis voilà qu'au dernier moment il y
en a plus qu'à Franck Colin ne va pas
être de ce voyage
le Falcon 50 se rend à Puerto Plata en
sur la côte nord de la République
Dominicaine Nicolas appart avec
les pilotes quoi puisque c'est eux qui
ont conduit l'avion jusqu'à là-bas
[Musique]
quelqu'un qui est d'un abord plaisant
qui aime les gens qui ça devrait
facilité à rentrer à rentrer en contact
je crois qu'il le fait de façon très
sincère surtout et on lui confie des
tâches commerciales ces tâches
commerciales vont être la prospection de
clientèle nouvelle elle parle le monde
qui sont à même encore une fois de
d'investir des capitaux par le biais de
la société qui l'emploie
[Musique]
et là il va se passer quelque chose
d'étonnant Nicolas pisadia le passager
va demander à ce que le retour pour
parler rapidement soit en destin que les
autorités reportuaires de sachent rien
de de ce vol retour à un voyage assez
curieux où alors qu'on est arrivé à
destination on a un passager qui reste
cloîtré dans son hôtel alors qu'il est
supposé prendre des contacts pour ses
affaires immobilières et qui va tenir ce
langage ça se présente sous des auspices
très particuliers
[Musique]
va décoller de Puerto Plata avec un
chargement très important un chargement
qui n'existait pas à l'aller Nicolas
puisatier comme il en simplement
j'allais dire un bagage à main enfin
juste ce qu'il faut pour voyager je
rappelle que que les pilotes ont
l'obligation de surveiller en permanence
leur appareil s'ils ne sont pas dans
l'appareils doivent fermer verrouiller
l'appareil donc comment ces valises
sont-elles retrouvées à l'intérieur on a
des pilotes qui sont totalement
évanescents est-ce qu'ils ont laissé
l'avion ouvert auquel cassé déjà une
faute de leur part il s'agissant du
chargement de l'avion les pilotes
doivent être présents ils doivent
surveiller chargement il faut qu'il
vérifie qu'il n'y ait pas un chargement
trop important par rapport à la
possibilité de l'avion il faut que ce
chargement soit placé dans l'avion de
manière à ne pas déséquilibrer la
violence ou au décollage sur
l'atterrissage soit même en vol quand on
s'arrête avec un avion
on a pas mal de choses à faire avec deux
sauf s'il y a une hôtesse donc on
partage les tâches en deux donc il y en
a un qui se qui reste plus près de
l'avion donc il s'occupe de du passage
qui va débarquer des personnels qui vont
graviter autour de l'avion faire le
plein etc et il y a un autre pilote un
des deux enfin c'est ça c'était ma
méthode qui va régler les affaires avec
l'aéroport payer les taxes donc sur ce
vol là retour c'est moi qui m'occupais
d'aller payer les taxes et donc je me
suis écarté d'avion j'ai pas assisté à
tout ce n'est pas au pilote et au
passager d'apporter leurs valises depuis
le tarmac jusqu'à dans l'avion il y a
une société qui s'appelle une société de
handling dont c'est le métier le pilote
doit ouvrir la soute la société de
handling le charge et ensuite il doit
vérifier que ces conformes de vie de
masse et centrages et c'est lui qui doit
fermer la soute faire le tour de
l'appareil et ensuite rentrer dans
l'avion il y a une vision on va dire
théorique et abstraite qui consiste à
dire le pilote doit être présent au
chargement et au déchargement et une
vision pratique qui consiste à dire oui
je suis présent au chargement mais comme
ça va durer 30 minutes si je vois que ça
se passe bien je vais faire d'autres
trucs pendant ce temps et je reviens
ils ne sont pas là et on comprend en
réalité que
l'avion était chargé en dehors de leur
contrôle ce qui n'est évidemment pas
normal
l'avion décolle de Puerto Plata
il s'arrête aux Açores il s'arrête d'un
soir pour deux raisons la première
raison c'est refaire un plein parce
qu'il y a quand même 11 heures de vol
Falcon c'est quand même un trois moteurs
il faut quand même recharger et la
raison principale c'est quoi c'est que
pour que y ait le minimum de risque à
l'arrivée c'est d'atterrir en venant
d'un espace Schengen sur les plans de
vol le trajet est pris en compte à
partir de la dernière escale
donc la dernière escale c'est les Açores
c'est donc le Portugal on est dans
l'espace Schengen
ça permet de considérer que ça n'est pas
un vol dont l'origine géographique est
suspecte à priori un vol qui vient de
République Dominicaine évidemment c'est
un vol qu'un douanier pourrait cibler
dans le cadre d'un contrôle
[Musique]
pas de vérifie là-bas non plus il y a
pas de douane qui vient tout contrôler
puisqu'ils savent que tu fais un plein
et que tu repars ils ont pas envie de
sortir leur cul de leur chaise pour
aller contre un avion qui va repartir
ils ont raison et ça se passe comme ça
tout le temps espace Schengen c'est
réglé les plans sont faits ils repartent
tranquillement il décolle et ils
arrivent à Saint-Tropez
[Musique]
moi mon sentiment de pilote c'était oui
ça accompli voilà parce que c'est un
Falcon 50 qui était assez ancien donc il
y a des pas équipés comme maintenant
sont les avions donc c'était assez
rustique tout est bien marché
à l'aide enfin avec l'expérience de
Pascal parce qu'il y en avait déjà fait
30 Atlantique on a évité tous les pièges
quoi et le retour c'est très bien passé
aussi au niveau aéronautique
ce jour-là c'était le dimanche 9
décembre 2012 on est vraiment dans une
période très calme il y a plus d'avions
qui atterrit à Saint-Tropez qui est
surtout utilisé l'été personne très peu
nombreuses une apparition pas furtive
mais assez rapide du directeur de
l'aéroport qui s'appelle Monsieur Pierre
Fourques le premier à être venu dans la
matinée alors qu'il est hors service que
ça n'est pas dans ses attributions
on a François-Xavier manché qui est là
et qui dit qu'il attend un ami qui
s'intéresse aussi à l'aviation c'est le
premier arrivé
son rôle à la moelle il était très clair
il est là il sait pourquoi il est là il
est pas là pour garder les oiseaux volés
à côté des avions il est là parce qu'il
sait qu'il y a un trafic dessus qui est
en vue d'être
commis sur la piste de la de l'aéroport
et il a accepté de toucher de l'argent
pour ça voilà c'est tout
François Xavier
de personnalité qui est totalement
incompatible avec la fonction de
douanier il a envie d'être aimé on lui a
demandé de venir il l'a fait
spontanément et effectivement il y a il
y a ces deux cette forme de bipolarité
ou enfin de personnalité double
grande intelligence mais immense
faiblesse affective
[Musique]
et on est là et on attend on sait qu'ils
vont pas tarder à arriver donc on
regarde et puis un moment donné au loin
on voit l'avion apparaître tu vois et
puis il se présentent tranquille il
vient bah il se pose et le temps est
bien il y a pas de vent on nous mois de
décembre il fait beau
[Musique]
l'avion arrive et là on va procéder au
déchargement de cet avion fort de sa
qualité de douanier François-Xavier
Manchet va obtenir l'ouverture des
portails et une première voiture va
circuler sur le tarmac et va se mettre
au pied de l'avion pour faciliter le
transbordement de ses valises
[Musique]
le premier véhicule va être rapidement
rempli un deuxième va arriver un
véhicule break on va remplir de deux
véhicules
[Musique]
un Agent de piste qui se trouve là à
essayer de rendre service il a essayé de
soulever une valise et c'est aperçu
qu'elle est en tout cas celle qui
voulait soulever était très lourde c'est
à ce moment là qu'on lui a demandé de
s'écarter et de pas toucher au
chargement Pascal Fauré aidé au
déchargement des valises alors ça
s'explique parce que la personne qui
était en charge des déodée chargement à
pas agi correctement et donc il a voulu
donner un coup de main pour que les
valises soient déchargées plus vite pour
que lui puisse rentrer plus vite chez
lui voilà et effectivement ça lui a pas
plu parce qu'elles étaient lourdes que
lui il est pilote pas lui qui doit aider
au déchargement qu'il l'a fait pour
rendre un coup de main puis c'est une
déchargement qui s'est fait
comme comme n'importe quel autre
déchargement ça a été dit que le pilote
avait été un peu violent machin et tout
c'est même pas je pense que si le pilote
avait été un peu sec c'est parce qu'il
était fatigué de savoir de s'être tapé
plusieurs heures de vol et ça s'arrête
là il y a personne qui roule des
mécaniques là c'était que des mecs
tranquille cool dans une atmosphère très
détendue
il y avait il y avait rien de stressant
en tous les cas pour moi il y avait un
stressant et autour de moi j'ai pas
senti de stress on est là en train de
parler avec le directeur de l'aéroport
on fume du clope on discute et voiture
s'en vont et puis nous on s'en va aussi
et chacun rentre chez soi
l'affaire est faite c'est à dire que
elle est bien faite
[Musique]
parce que
moi mon état d'esprit à cette période là
je suis je suis au dessus de tout je
suis sur mon nuage moi
le capitaine
oui bonjour je souhaiterais faire un
signalement
[Musique]